hello everyone it is time to watch the
official showcase for ghostwire tokyo
this is a game coming out on ps5 on
march 25th and i am super excited about
it it was one of the ones from i think
the reveal last year maybe the year
before i don't know what time is anymore
that i was very interested in um i
believe this is a bethesda game and it
started i hope i'm i'm correct about
this um as a sequel to evil within so
evil within three but then shifted into
something else um so i'm expecting
horror vibes i really enjoyed evil
within i feel like it's the closest
thing we have kind of to a modern day
silent hill that isn't indie um
so yeah let's let's jump into it i don't
really know what to expect from this i
don't feel like we've seen a ton of this
game i'm super hyped check it out
it's definitely evil within
type imagery that's right it has the
magic stuff i kind of forgot about that
like that's such an interesting thing to
include in this kind of game
foreign
i wonder welcome to ghost wire tokyo
open supernatural action adventure
thriller set in an eerie haunting vision
of tokyo
with explosive first-person combat
and dangerous monsters said it's cool
comeback does look fun oh this game's
gonna be terrifying i can't wait all of
tokyo's population mysteriously vanishes
the city is flooded with supernatural
creatures hell yeah headless cheerleader
our story begins here in the fallout of
the vanishing i think this will be the
next game that is the deserted streets
of tokyo with an unknown voice
and strange elemental powers coursing
through your veins
possessed by a mysterious spirit named
kk who has his own agenda you'll need to
work together to unravel the truth
behind the disappearances
and save the city from this twisted
nightmare
oh man
you'll harness an arsenal of powerful
abilities through a mystic art known as
ethereal weaving jubilee
channeling raw ether that's really
impressively animated
fire
and water oh
yeah because we've only seen like
touches of it before their hands
upgrade and master these abilities that
animation is placed
incorporating powerful choreographs
and perfectly timed blocks sweet
devastating effect it's like a parry
system inside of a survival horse
alongside your abilities you'll have a
range of more traditional and mystical
tools at your disposal
traversal and exploration are a central
part of ghostwire tokyo
and with the tengu ability
players can grapple and maneuver through
the city with ease
wow
areas of dense fog not only harbor dark
energy that drains your health but are
infested with deadly paranormal
creatures
to clear these infected areas you'll
need to cleanse corrupted tory gates
scattered throughout the city i wonder
what the narrative is going to be
like this seems freeing untethered souls
more open world require experience to
upgrade your ethereal abilities wow it
is really unique i've not seen
tokyo you'll discover strange
distortions in reality known as
spaces where time
and space themselves cannot be trusted
and the only way to create control
is to power through them
in this video we want to bring together
these mechanics to show you the world's
first extended gameplay preview yeah i'd
like to see commission i'd like to see
what you what
what we picked up at a moment where you
know keto and kk have been separated i
guess evil within was leaving with only
his wits and traditional weapons
aikido must track the spirit down
sneak attacks and core grabs are a great
way to clear your path without
attracting unwanted attention
they don't look that hard to fight
though like just based on the but maybe
we were seeing somebody's level about
like it seems like you could just fight
everybody
which is going to be an interesting
thing when it comes to balancing the
fear factor if you have a lot of power
you're less likely to feel
afraid
he cute all right
a little pouty boy
okay
good to know
m
i wonder if just like regular civilians
still live in tokyo whoa
look at his little teeth
a big fan of the the headless girl
[Music]
i feel like there are so many raincoat
killers in
japanese games and there was a raincoat
killer in japan
now that you're reunited with kk you can
use his powers again
and gain access to devastating
supercharged attacks interesting from
now on as you fight you'll charge your
synergy with kk at full charge you can
enter wire in mode to boost your powers
looks very cool i don't know how fun
exactly that would have been to play but
to grapple between buildings because it
seemed a little sweet
on to the nearest tengu yo
of course of course of course very
distracting
these creatures are not only the fastest
way to get around but they also open a
new dimension to the city
the corrupted tory gate is just ahead
cleanse it to clear out some of the
sinister fog throughout the city
[Music]
i wonder what kind of okay i was gonna
be like what attacks did they do to you
though
that's a parry system that's cool i love
a power system put that in every game
as you progress your powers will grow
and with many enemy archetypes to fight
you'll need to evolve your abilities and
strategies to take on these supernatural
threats
that's cool
i'm annoyed that they cut though like i
wanted to see what a full mission looks
like okay
so like i don't have an understanding of
like the structure of
explore the city i don't know also find
other tools and weapons because it does
seem pretty open
to expand your combat options
this combat looks
sick though i can't wait to try it
using spectral vision city looks pretty
nice visitors and other points of
interest as you make your way through
tokyo oh yes the scan every game has of
course
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm hearing dogs
[Applause]
just like flippy headless
school students
combat looks really fun i still have a
lot of questions
more questions than i expected
i'm gonna play this game regardless whoa
that's some design um
like no question i will definitely play
it oh there's still so much left
did they just run it no
three days access on playstation if you
pre-order
that's pretty cool
[Music]
this is a trailer
yeah i still have a lot of questions
nope that's a real man
shinji makami hello
[Applause]
um
[Music]
it's two
[Music]
okay that's that is cool it is it is
always nice to see a japanese game set
in
japan like lately we've been seeing
western studios make game set in
japanese studios to make games
[Music]
way less people
[Music]
[Music]
uh
it's an action adventure
[Music]
foreign
foreign
i know most of those things
interesting yeah i did not realize it
was an action adventure
it makes sense that you caught that's
like like i was saying i wonder how
they're going to balance make you play
with crazy
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah because it seems like it's
raining virtually all the time
that was a choice
[Music]
i don't
i've always really liked him
cool that's neat yeah it definitely um
explains the things i was confused about
um
i guess they have to note that now huh
um
yeah it explains the things that i was
like how is this gonna work it makes
sense if it's an action adventure again
means i probably won't do a whole
playthrough of the game on the channel
but i will for sure be playing it very
curious about how mission structure is
going to work so i like it when these
leave me with a couple more questions i
don't just understand what this game is
yet um they have some interesting things
there that i want to see how they
approach them
otherwise
definitely going to play it excited to
try out the combat uh let's go
2022 i feel like is pretty good year for
video games i'm looking forward to it
let me know what you guys think